the presidential change is also big for
saturday night live donald trump pushed
their ratings through the roof
but now what we have all the answers
kicking off tonight's
roll call how did you even get into the
white house
i won more votes i just want to do her
proud listen
i have good news e.t can report maya
will continue playing the vp
but who's playing the president i've got
the beginning of 46
fantastic ideas hell i'm like colonel
sanders every time you see me i'm a
different guy
following in the footsteps of jason
sudeikis and jim carrey e.t has learned
alex moffitt will continue as biden
as for trump it'll only take a minute
we're told alec will likely be back too
but nbc hasn't set a date for snl's
return
they typically start back up on the
final weekend in january
next is josh dumel stepping in for army
hammer for me it's been an opportunity
to
sort of reboot e.t can confirm the actor
is in very early
talks to join jlo in shotgun wedding
this after army announced he was
stepping down from the rom-com amid
controversy over his alleged disturbing
dms
armies basically denied sending them
using an expletive to describe the
claims
shooting on the movie is imminent and
josh was eager to start this year with a
bang
i'm looking forward to 2021 sailor v2020